speaking of religion I must break away
here we have the very special guest I
wanted to have her on for a long time
she's an actress and the creator and
host today in East Scientology in the
aftermath
please welcome Leah Remini
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
let me try to calm down from the panel
take a moment you need some water no I
do but reaming and arguing to be with
someone who I admire greatly because
I've been watching your show and I am
telling you I could admirer of what you
are doing okay and you know I think when
when the history of Scientology is
finally written it's going to show that
you know you had a faith chose you thank
you to come in like in act 5 right
you're like you're like Reagan with you
know tear down that wall thank you and
you know we had going clear yes
documentary on our network yeah it's
awesome
yes it started to break the wall down
exactly like what you are doing is
putting a human face on the people who
suffer from this awful cult thank you I
really appreciate that and you're right
it's about families right it's about
families but it's about the damage that
it does to people as individuals I mean
we're all still kind of managing who we
are from being in a cult it's it's not
an easy thing which you've every right
child I mean I was a child and most
people are who get in because it really
wasn't a religion I used that weasely of
its time right um so I I think they're
going to be hard-pressed to find new
members however I I felt a
responsibility because as somebody who
was a Scientologist for over 35 years
you know what they disseminate was that
we were responsible for mankind and so
there was an annulment yes we but read
that what you were helping we thought we
were helping and that's why it's hard to
come out I'm in a tough position because
on one hand I'm attacking this cult and
at the same time I know that the people
who are still in are under this dispell
of doing good for the world because
that's what the the organ is what I'm
not a great thing that came out on your
show that really explained a lot to me
about how otherwise intelligent people
who I knew some of them
be in this cult I mean I would say any
religion but especially this one
and you really put this out there that
what it is is you're audited if they're
always questioning you what did you do
what did you see
Franco it just doesn't pay to look on
the internet because you know you're
going to have to answer that question in
an audit that you just don't look well
you just don't know somebody told me the
first time you found out some about
Scientology was when you saw my movie
Religulous exactly so I want well
forever well first of all I wasn't
allowed with Scientologists aren't
allowed to look at things like this
we're not allowed to look or listen to
people who are critics of Scientology so
I I watched it because I was a
troublemaker apparently always and I
watched it now I wasn't at the level
that you were just what you were
revealing in your documentary I wasn't
even at that level yet so you seemed a
little crazy to me because I didn't know
what you were saying was true something
like that shit's crazy right but then as
you get to the upper levels and now I
want you to know that it's confidential
so a lot of people don't even reach this
confidential level in Scientology and
you're like Bill Maher's got the real
[ __ ] right right oh you are technically
correct in the way you said it and I
should tell you you know and this is uh
this is just a I want to say this to the
press and people who talked about
Scientology is you should always talk to
somebody who was in because if you don't
get the nomenclature 100% correct we
have a way of just kind of discrediting
you from the if you're not using it
correctly so you didn't say exactly but
you're on the right track okay I didn't
but but you don't know this until three
hundred thousand dollars later and then
you're really another great thing I
learned from you show you and if you
said it always sticks with me you said
when you go to a Scientology event and
you look in the parking lot every one of
the cars is a cheap shitty old car
right because Scientology sucks all the
money all right
all of this correct my mother's laughing
because she's in the audience and she's
only one of the nice cars I bought it
for her
but that that is I mean it reminded me a
lot of communism yeah because like
communism first of all you're poor they
take all your money yeah and also the
snitching on each other crap everybody's
watching each other I mean again this is
the great thing about your show it shows
disconnecting if people that they ask
you to disconnect from your own family
they don't escape leave against each
other yes they don't ask you it's a
requirement right and and they the
church thinks they're they have
outsmarted the press because it is
incorrect to say that across all boards
you have to disconnect from anyone who
talks about Scientology the truth of the
matter is the policies because
everything is run by policy in
Scientology there's no room for
assimilation there's no what did you
think what did you get from that
you know Idris what the [ __ ] does it say
and if you don't understand it you know
do a clay demo of it and you get checked
out on policies like what is the word
and mean and you need to know 25
definitions of the word and and its
derivations so you so yes so it's it's
almost it is exactly thought my love was
but yeah exactly yeah so yeah well you
are law you got nothing on her science
already already correct about that but
the UH the the the problem there is that
we're self brainwashing which a cult
accident actually told us that Cephas on
in our last special and I didn't realize
that because we are required to study
two and a half hours a day daily like
minimum minimum so we are looking at the
words we are being checked out on on the
policies but even like I know they're
big on celebrities even Oracle liberties
have to do this yet only Tom Cruise does
this yes yes not only does Tom Cruise do
exactly that now it now I don't want you
to get the idea that he's not that
certain policies are not being bent for
him because they are and that is the
truth and that was part of the hypocrisy
he could end this he didn't a single
handedly crack he is the one for crack
and and because and because they're
saying that he single-handed
is clearing a planet is changing the
planet so most Scientologists believe a
planet he couldn't even make jack
reacher ahead well Scientologists
believe that he did
ok Scientology and Scientologists
believe that if he didn't make it a hit
it was because they were suppressive
evil people working against him because
he's winning in life and he's clearing
the planet so we're just going to be in
ten years I mean III think you really
are playing a very key part and just
it's about to fall and then I think
we're you know I hope so I mean I hope
so because it's not something yes and
it's not something to make fun of it's
not something because actually people
are going to hurt but you can make fun
of it but but I also want you to be the
player on your show who I'll be X
Scientology yeah see it's like wow I
didn't know there was a real world I
want to play the Louie Armstrong song
for them what a wonderful world you know
you know you know I can breathe and you
know what that you know sure we don't we
don't know this world you know so you're
absolutely right and that's what I want
to celebrate it but these people keep
doing survivor so thank you you're doing
God's work
[Applause]